the villain from one flew over the
cuckoo's nest is coming to netflix in
her own series called ratchet
we're here to give you the lowdown on
this electric new show from who's
playing the infamous nurse to the talent
behind the camera
so where and when can you watch ratchet
the show is coming to netflix and from
the sound of things there's already a
multi-season arc planned out
netflix reportedly signed the show up
for two seasons right out of the gate
and star sarah paulson has revealed
plans for at least four seasons saying
in 2019
ideally by the time we're in season four
we're in that story of the cuckoo's nest
when will the series hit the streaming
service the first season is set to debut
on september 18th
2020. like all netflix series ratchet
will be released in its entirety on that
day giving you eight episodes to watch
if you want to binge the whole thing on
day
one
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're keeping score the novel one
flew over the cuckoo's nest was released
in 1962
and the film version was released in
1975. really it's about time we added
something new to this classic tale of
conformity and individualism
nurse ratchet is one of the most iconic
film villains of all time
so it goes without saying that a
powerhouse actor is needed to take on
the role
in the 1975 film louise fletcher was
that actress
fletcher actually won the only oscar of
her storied career for playing the
uncaring nurse
luckily the ratchet series has a pretty
strong successor to fletcher in the lead
role
sarah paulson paulson is probably best
known for her work in the american
horror
story and american crime story anthology
series for which she has won numerous
awards but she has plenty of other
strong work on her resume
highlights include glass 12 years a
slave bird box and miss america
paulson excels at portraying complex
characters to the point that she seems
to have astonishingly few limits to her
talent
suburban mom with an illegal side hustle
she's got it covered in ocean's eight
marcia clark lead prosecutor in the
infamous o.j simpson murder case
she'll win an emmy and hit the red
carpet with the very woman she portrays
anyone who's seen paulson in action
knows that she will nail the role of
nurse ratchet with a plum
and bring the character to life for a
whole new generation of fans
what are you gonna do about it what are
you deaf no
just thinking of all the things i'm
going to do about it
sarah paulson isn't the only actor to
get excited about in ratchet she'll be
accompanied by a sparkling mix of big
names and up-and-coming talents
including sharon stone judy davis
vincent d'onofrio
cynthia nixon and rosanna arquette
besides those major names there are a
few other familiar faces you might
notice in ratchet
alfred ruben thomas has listed his
appearing in over a dozen episodes as
albert allison
you might recognize him from sons of
anarchy hunter perish from weeds amanda
plummer from pulp fiction and corey
stoll of ant-man are a few other actors
who might catch your eye
if you're unfamiliar with the finer
points of nurse ratchet's character
here's a primer
she's the antagonist of one flew over
the cuckoo's nest the head nurse of a
mental ward where she rules with
ironclad authority
nurse ratchet is an expert in
psychological manipulation
knowing just what buttons to push to
keep her charges cowed
that changes when brash uncontrollable
mcmurphy is admitted to the ward and
promptly starts a war for control with
nurse ratchet
the results of this conflict are
calamitous for everyone involved
most horrifically ratched's manipulation
of one patient's anxieties pushes him to
take his own life
netflix's ratchet will be a prequel
story that begins in 1947
following mildred ratchet as she moves
from job to job presumably leaving ruin
and terror in her wake
as paulson hinted by the series n the
story may sync up with that of the 1975
classic
surprisingly ratchet seems to have
little to do with its famous source
material beyond its focus on the novel
and movie's iconic villain
a look through the character list does
not indicate any familiar characters
from the novel or movie
at this point it doesn't look like we'll
see harding billy chief romden or anyone
else from the ward on the show
though they may be included in future
seasons executive producer ryan murphy
has also indicated an intention to
produce four seasons of ratchet
as he told slash film he plans for one
flew over the cuckoo's nest mcmurphy to
show up as an adversary in the fourth
season if you're familiar with the
events of the book or the iconic jack
nicholson performance you know what's in
store
one other way ratchet is tied to
cuckoo's nest comes from michael douglas
who is a producer on the series
he produced the 1975 film as well and
ryan murphy has said that douglas is
heavily involved in many aspects of the
series including casting and his
involvement likely bodes well for fans
of the original film
one of the major reasons we're so pumped
for ratchet is the impressive slate of
people helping bring it to life
ryan murphy co-creator executive
producer and one of the directors of the
show comes to mind immediately in this
regard
his impressive success with series like
american horror story glee scream queens
and hollywood all point towards another
slam dunk series
murphy himself would direct the first
two episodes then hand things off to
nelson crack
who has worked as a director and
cinematographer on other murphy series
like poe's and american crime story
michael uppendahl jennifer lynch daniel
menehen and jessica u will all get a
crack at later episodes of ratchet
with up and doll being the only other
director besides murphy slated to handle
two episodes
daniel minahan who has directed episodes
of series including hollywood and game
of thrones will direct the season 1
finale
in short the people in charge of ratchet
have a lot of experience with the sort
of show it appears to be
experimental visually distinct and
boundary pushing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
new shows on netflix are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one